[Music]
that backfired news submitted by Jones
Vietnam adventures Oh baby how long were
you there drunk two weeks two weeks I
was like dang bro this looks fine but
trying to convince my wife to go to
Vietnam why I just feel like I want to
visit there and she just like Nam no I
mean like white why is she saying nah
she's scared of everything
yeah it's not one of those countries
that is easy to navigate
see I don't say that man okay well she's
not watching them because that when I
told let's go to Japan she's my god but
what if they get bombed by North Korea
Japan is safer than here that's what we
could say here we get mom you you get
you have white privilege and you're not
even why yes yeah
tourist privilege yeah a department
store is under fire after asking its
menstruating staff to wear period badges
oh look yeah that's not why I bet that
sentence was going at least now you know
why everyone's act like a [ __ ]
yeah cuz I'd be like why are you being
so harassed okay period badge okay and
I'm like no no matter what you say I
know it's your menstrual cycle talking
and now we can communicate yeah I know
I'll see you personally help some
relationships people were menstruating
exactly oh yes so this badge was
proposed as part of this new store zone
zone die maru metas new store zone and
so oh this isn't japan by the way yeah
and so this is in collaboration with a
cycle tracking app called luna luna and
so they the store was focusing on
women's sexuality and menstrual health
by selling lingerie sanitary
herbal medicine and bedding for
menstruating women and so they decided
to give this as an option to workers
that are like they were encouraging
female employees to wear period badges
when they were menstruating and it
completely backfired because it featured
this manga character named Oh No
yuri-chan
they reach 10 which loosely translates
to Little Miss period
so I tried to sell what the cute that
looks like a Gen 7 pokeyman nose is a
[ __ ] controller being like a hose
like a it's like a cross like a little
like like Red Cross kind of thing that's
[ __ ] that's this is this criminy why
what was the point
like what this is supposed to be like I
think it's supposed to be like period
pride or something don't be don't be
ashamed of it like I almost thought that
it was going for like they're trying to
like be like Oh like this person can
give you recommendations on things
because she's on a rack right now he too
is also going to say that could be the
way they thought of it but it was not
translated like that really receive that
way that's because it looks so silly if
it was a dragon that was like I think
it'd be dad that would be received by
okay yeah that's what it should look
like not I mean that's actually what it
feels like you're right yeah right I
know Nikki talks no time she's like it
feels like my blood is boiling under my
skin though Mike I'm gonna leave blood
boiling on your skin oh we're all good
all women are exactly the same tips so
please speak no because I've actually I
don't have periods that extreme I'm not
like that I don't get a badge you don't
get a bang no I mean I've experienced
cramps but like when I first got my
period like I don't usually get cramps I
don't usually PMS that I think I PMS he
might attack my wife don't hopefully she
doesn't see this episode whoo later in
life she's on something else
a bee-like bra she won't let no
arguments go and I you know even if
she's on a pier you can't bring it up
that's typical symptoms yes
just like oh yeah Nikes not even my
fault you didn't get me pregnant this
month now you're gonna pay the pregnancy
is even worse than period that's why I
heard you really did that you did that
to me there's something to blame you for
I was pregnant by her last trimester was
in the summer she was hot tea sweaty
hungry I remember one time never forget
this we were watching TV was 937 and
Famous Dave's commercial for ribs came
on she's like that because I was like
yeah that would be good she was like
that'd be good yeah would I get the
rhythm like 15 minutes she was like so I
just had your baby oh I'm having your
kids and you can't give me no ribs so I
literally have the it was raining in
Washington I had to get there called
them on the way hey I'm on the way we're
close I was like my wife wants RIF she's
nine months pregnant they're like
alright I gotta go get her ribs I got
there like 953 make the rest of me she
throws brick through the window what is
it is it like they're just going through
it making a human the hormones are
someone crazier than the regular PMS
yeah good I mean like what is going
through your body like it when I think
you're producing more estrogen and
testosterone crazy so they're just going
nuts like they're on they're coming down
off of drugs or something
yes and you're just right they're not
you're not big you don't have sore boobs
I mean what's happening billions of
people have done it it's not that
remarkable chicks should climb the [ __ ]
down a little bit only be like the first
person on Mars we'll all know their name
forever right nobody won't know that
name what the [ __ ] hundred billion
person on Mars nobody gives a [ __ ]
deal with it deal with it
but yeah so uh yeah I can't I don't have
crazy-ass periods like this abandoning a
pregnant woman doesn't sound like a bad
idea anymore you know what athletes are
actually smart oh man they do that
yeah Tiki Barber did that he left his
wife while she was pregnant got a hold
another girl uh they just keep popping
out more kids but they leave at the
right moment see cuz it doesn't [ __ ] up
their game well dude that Buccaneers
team was [ __ ] good he's stressed at
work and then comes home he's stressed
with a pregnant wife like no thank you
yeah we need them to win well we got
them pregnant yeah that's what I was
about to say thanks [ __ ] you wanted a
[ __ ] kid too you'd wanted to come up
in that [ __ ] too so yes I didn't see
that coming from the beginning of that
sentence but then we did the first time
my wife got pregnant man I messed up
nose long tube and she was tripping and
then she got pregnant again
and fun fact when we're moving to LA cuz
she didn't want kids she was on birth
control all that stuff um to remove to
LA and I had a she had a box of purses
and I'd like dumped it out to pack him
and the pack of birth control pills fell
out
she only eaten 17 of that month and I
was like hey what's this she was like
who was born that year no they say is
that uh yeah I think I lost them and
that's where the kid came from she just
stopped that day 17 in and then he was
born sporting tells Daisy that story
ends oh yeah it's funny cuz she always
gets on my kids and they act over like
maybe she's like you gave me a c-section
scar to my youngest yeah like not say
that's Daisy
he was the first he gave her a c-section
scar you just reopened they just cut
them and that's let me tell you guys a
weird story since we're talking about
periods in pregnancy so when my wife was
getting the second kid right she had a
c-section I was able to be in there and
they like you know like use like a
little blowtorch almost wasn't even I
feels like like fire
Yeah right open her up they have like
makes a lot of sense but I didn't know I
was expecting like a scalpel I did
expect like yeah and they want something
for the blow you smell it - yes burning
flashing like something you're not
prepared for
so then they're like dumping water in in
the like open wound and stuff and the
doctor the whole time she's literally
like cutting it's definitely not you see
dude I was freaking out I was on a TV
screen over over it was crazy so the
doctors just having a conversation about
how she's gonna reach our floor she's
like yes so I'm going with the Italian
marble because you know we're thinking
about granite but I was like man then I
thought if she's thinking like that this
must be so routine for her that she's
good that's what I'm saying that's the
only big company now that also means
billions of women have done it so yeah
that was that was and they pull the baby
out by the way they're disgusting the
movies lied to me there oh dude it's
like an alien they're all kind of colors
there's blood everywhere you go put it
back and [ __ ] let it bake a little
longer to hold it over something out of
alien though for real like you pulled it
out too early
yeah it's no then after the first bath
they look super cute my eyelid like here
on a soda is a hella
hello my name it was [ __ ] perfect was
he yeah he was my shoulder fur or not no
shoulder my kids had that but it wasn't
like dark like he guys because the same
kind of like hair that I have which is
like really light like blondish yeah
that's why I'm knockin so are you saying
your wife was already kind of like fiery
and then she's pregnant and it's just
like Oh God she wasn't fiery at all and
the pregnancy was like let me change her
yeah it changed her her molecular
biology so my wife's fiery now maybe the
pregnancy will turn a little opposite
it's gonna be hard times ten oh please
you never know like things are gonna get
mixed in with that seething anger you
know like the Phoenix right Nikki times
ten is just like it's like a volcano
times ten oh my gosh [ __ ] you need a
loving mask yeah yeah just keep the Cavs
man because your kids are gonna grow up
and then eventually you're gonna be
corny to them I know no matter who
creams dad yes even the Bron James kids
look at him what cringe you could see
the kids attack oh yeah he's the corny
dad just like me you were two three like
that doesn't have to seven or anything
not even a big number
[Music]